jalen rose from the mothership former
NBA player on loan from the morning show
with greenie and beetle the get-ups and
jaylen joins us now did they have a
combine NBA combine when you were coming
out of Michigan they did have an NBA
combine to be honest with you by the way
I appreciate after you have any
opportunity to lose their stop I can
appreciate the prowess of understanding
how fast someone is how strong someone
is their miracles are obviously
important when you're evaluating the
player so to not diminish that part of
it but it just always was to me that we
only see that take place at basketball
and football but we never see a take
place in baseball and or hockey which
sometimes give sort of a meat market
feel to it yeah and I'm just with that
being said I actually should have gone
to the combine even though I was an
all-american and played in a couple of
national championship games or whatnot I
think I participating hurt my drive
stock I was uniquely hanging out with
the number one pick who was a friend of
mine Lee Roberts and we both showed up
and we were supposed to do as far as the
paperwork and we both left well he went
number one and then I fill in the draft
so hindsight means I probably should
have taken that part of a little bit
more seriously what is the most
important trait you would look for in
any basketball player they have to have
what mine is the one that you can't
measure how much somebody loves
basketball
why are you doing this because of what
comes with it are you doing it for the
law because I like people that have a
motor when they play the game and are
forced to play somebody that's going to
work out and train and do all the things
but also turn around and play five on
five three 101 just somebody to just is
in love with it
not that you can't have other interests
the other 21 hours you're not in the gym
in theory but just people that love the
game other than the obvious critter
folks you're gonna take somebody with
the same skill set this taller if you're
building your team so for example if
Kevin Durant step turn are about to get
drafted
you're gonna take Cadiz because he's
almost seven so how important is that
this game three to the future of LeBron
and the Cavaliers on Saturday I think
it's important to the Cavaliers three
you're not coming back I don't
necessarily think this game in
particular is gonna be a driving force
to whether LeBron actually stays in
Cleveland this summer or Alize
I think that yet to be determined and
myself along with so many other media
members are gonna irresponsibly report
where he might go on to the excellent
users and so I think it's just more
important for him to continue to play
the way he's been playing and role
players usually perform better at home
and that's what I expect when he would
in Game three
all right not I don't want you to tell
me what you think he'll do I want you to
tell me what you would do if you were
LeBron if I was LeBron relationships he
has around the league and uniquely
positioned because again people forget
the Bron James while talking basketball
in the game and if the best player is
also become a mogul where his longtime
friend rich Paul as an agency represents
players that he plays with and over
again
Bennett please absolutely and I'll plays
alongside to overbeat people are going
to speculate should he go there ago say
word
hey if you want to go join the super
team watch you just go join a team or
the Warriors go make the cap state is
necessary for LeBron they go join that
squad people are going to speculate a
lot of graduates right oh yeah the whole
mob there maybe you could play he and
Paul George and or boogie cousins
together in the coupling show but if the
Houston Rockets words who
they were annoying his friendship with
Chris Paul their God their Godfather's
to each other's kids and whatnot I would
think that that would probably be the
place I would go with all things equals
LeBron James if I was leaving Cleveland
he's Jalen Rose of ESPN former NBA
player joining us Dan Patrick show I was
trying to come up with an analogy
because we always do this I or
comparison with what we see with James
Harden that who does he remind you of
and you know people came up with Gilbert
Arenas which I didn't think at the time
but is there an apt comparison to harden
the way he plays thankfully and
greatness he's one of the more unique
players the game his knee and those who
want to quantify it here huh do arenas
who wouldn't lead the league in assists
has done that and he's amongst the top
two or three plus he leads the league in
scoring now they're only been a couple
of guys to lead the league at total
points and total with this and there's
only been one guy to do it in the same
season which was telling the archer ball
so based on that if you look around the
league you'd say okay he's a better
quote/unquote scored in LeBron James
he's more efficient at Russell Westbrook
he's more of a playmaker than KD and so
he just a unique player in today's game
and obviously based on how the rules
have been designed when you take as many
threes as he does Plus take his leave me
free throws as he does that also is a
trait that you don't normally see in the
same player Jalen good to catch up with
you as always have a good weekend and
hope things are going well with the show
thanks for joining us thanks for the
love appreciated for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
you
[Music]